rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message live a balanced life
over you go Olga Paul - most often if
not always a life seemed to be out of
balance and when lives are out of
balance it makes us very irritable you
know when we drive a car we always drive
a car and a car has four wheels a
rhetorical thing to say isn't it you
drive a car on these four wheels and
these four wheels in the car of life
represent first we your personal life
your health your mind yourself the
things that you love to do the things
that you would want to do not have to do
most times we live a life of have to do
I have to study I have to work I have to
pay my bills I have to pay the taxes I
have to do this and I have to do that I
have to go for the social function I
don't have a choice I have to have to
have to have to where did the love to go
we just end up living a life of half
twos and I forgot about our own cells by
subscribing to the pressures that come
from all fronts in our lives we've
forgotten to live our own lives we don't
have time to unwind we don't have time
to spend with our own selves we don't
have time to be with nature and take a
deep breath and just relish the
crispness of the air we don't have the
time to do all of that especially in a
metropolitan city like this when the
pressures are so high and the pace is so
fast we just don't have time for
ourselves ladies and gentleman and
that's one car one we love our car isn't
it personal life or health for instance
such an important thing but at the cost
of this running if you forget to pay
attention to our own else the second
wheel of the car is family life demands
attention isn't it your personal life
demands attention your family life
demands attention isn't it before
marriage when you are in love they call
it a crush isn't it but after marriage
all that is left is candy crush all the
crushes are in gone and all that you're
left with is a candy crush and all the
headaches coming from all the pressures
one lady went to a doctor and the doctor
said how's your headache madam she said
he's out of town gosh I must tell you
demands a lot of attention your personal
life
the first tire do you have one do you
have a personal life is my question do
you have time for your health
even in my hectic schedule I have made
five days of exercise yes still in all
the lectures and all the talks and
everywhere I go because that's what's
going to keep me going I have to give
time to myself because I don't get more
than three and a half to four hours of
sleep so if I don't look at my physical
fitness I'm gone ladies and gentlemen do
you give time for yourself do you have
time for yourself your personal type or
is that wheel out of balance is that a
flat tire the third we tire of the car
of life is your professional life your
personal life needs attention your
family life needs attention your
professional life needs attention and
the fourth is your social life your
friends people around you your
colleagues those relationships that
matter a lot to you those people who
would support you in time of need
because to your spouses to your family
you could speak a little sometimes
certain things are not always confided
with just blood relationships you need
that social side people do we can speak
open up your heart
how often do we just carry this baggage
of stress and load anxiety and worry in
our heads lugging it all around us
baggage
this is a social psych to our life a
friends I have had those moments where
I've snapped even as a monk because I'm
a human being this is because I put this
robes of a monk doesn't mean I become
you know a celestial angel I'm still a
human being when one of those tires is
out of order if I haven't slept well if
my health is out of place I'm going to
snap out you know you carry work
pressures at home you carry home
pressures at work ladies in German
irritability is a symptom of an out of
balance life stability in our responses
is a symptom of a life in balance we are
irritable we snap we react at the drop
of a hat for trivia just because we are
out of balance people who have a
balanced life know how to handle
pressure people whose lives are not
balanced sink under pressure and get so
irritable at little things they just
kind of snap off so I really love the
idea of the car and the analogy that he
told what I would add to it is that not
every tire needs to be inflated to the
same amount as everybody else and I
think what often happens is for some
people they care a lot more about the
career so some people they care a lot
more about their family the percentage
in the relationships are different for
each person ultimately what you have to
figure out is what balance means for you
I remember watching a clip of the rock
Dwayne Johnson I love that guy and for
him a balanced life means before he ever
gets
on set to shoot a film he needs to get
his workout in and he has a crazy
workout and so he'll wake up three to
four hours before he ever has to go out
on on film set and workout and to me
that sounds crazy
you know I'm filming today I'm gonna
make 25 big videos and another 50 or so
like micro videos I could not imagine
waking up three to four hours before
coming here to workout I did 25 push-ups
before I came here that was my work
that's it I could not imagine waking up
through the four hours early and doing a
full workout and then coming here to me
that is not a balanced life but it
doesn't matter to him he understands
what balance looks like for him and he
does his life and I think that's what's
really important we can learn from all
these different people and look at what
they do in their schedule and ultimately
though you can't judge them you can't
say Duane he's crazy that's that's crazy
out of balance not for him that's what
he wants and so if you're modeling
success and you're learning from dwayne
johnson or me or whoever it is that
you're looking up to you try it you look
at their morning routine or they're
balanced life when you try it in yours
and see if it makes sense it's
ultimately we shouldn't be judging
somebody else's perception of balance
but figuring out what balance looks like
for us and so we're all driving these
cars down the road down the highway
every single day but how much we inflate
each tire you have to figure that out on
your own and that's the game so the
question today is I'm curious what does
a balanced life mean to you how are you
spreading your time out amongst the four
tires in an ideal way I'd love to hear
from you leave it down in the comments
below I also want to give a quick shout
out to Albert or caso thank you so much
man for picking up a copy of my book and
doing the shout out on your YouTube
channel
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events pressive
expresso give me go
it's a very conscious effort for me to
do something that challenges me every
year I do one of those but I also do
those where I can put my hair down and
just look pretty I'm a girl I love doing
it
I love blockbuster hindi movies it's my
favorite genre film whether it's in
Hollywood or in Bollywood you take me
for an x-men I would much rather go see
that then I would see a film which tells
me a serious story I'm that audience
yeah sometimes I feel as an actor I
don't get pushed and challenged as much
but you can't always be doing the same
thing I and I like the Will Smith's way
of doing movies you do these big movies
with big money and big budgets and
they're commercial and they're
successful and you look hardening look
great and then you do that so you have
to be able to balance both very few
actors get to do it and I'm very I'm
glad that I'm part of that elite group
so you were an actor whose philosophy is
to work or to wait are you more of a
like I'm not going to do anything until
I find the right thing or you're just
like I should be working in a little bit
of a workaholic but but I can't but I
need to I feel like I like to take my
time I want to be able to select what I
should do I like to explore try to
explore different things different types
of of experiences but movies select you
and by that I mean a director and a
script
they are the ones that are going to
throw the party and you want to be you
want to go to the best party you know we
used the metaphor of a party for a movie
so a good director and a interesting
story will always you know dominate the
choices that I make or control the
choices that I make because if right now
is a great director with an interesting
script comes to me and wants me to do a
character that might not be a huge
stretch but to be involved with a what a
team movies are not made alone team is
teamwork that always will be like a
exciting and might take the first place
a good team might take first place but I
like to take my time but but I like to
work too so you know there's a good
balance you know just keep a good
balance
I don't think waiting to sometimes just
good to wait because you get exhausted
after doing movies you know kind of like
you know I give it give it a lot of
energy so I'm kind of like exhausted but
but you know a balance you know I might
wait for a little bit and then do one to
two movies almost back to back now did
you have any conversations with Pedro
Hera who voiced the character didn't
know anime today it's interesting I've
done a few movies where I play you know
someone play my character before all
that you know my character exists in
real life and I've always chosen I've
always chosen not to I think because in
the act of creation you do you want to
make sure that you're that you're
bringing something individual and
original and a big part of it was
wanting to stay faithful to the to the
original telling and I think I hope we
really got the balance right of being
like okay we're gonna offer you some new
stuff that you've never seen before but
we're also going to give you the heart
of
when you give me the one once equals one
words volume you have the most important
word ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
up or that would be like a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details